[Musique]
et
là monsieur bonsoir quatre morts une
quarantaine de blessés à la suite d'une
mystérieuse explosion
cet après midi au coeur de paris dans la
station saint-michel du rer
le président jacques chirac s'est rendu
sur les lieux ainsi qu'alain juppé
pour le premier ministre rien ne permet
pour l'instant de dire qu'il s'agit d'un
attentat mais les présomptions sont
extrêmement fortes
immédiatement l'état major des sapeurs
pompiers a déclenché le plan rouge
reportage maryse burgot bernard pis si
il est un peu plus de 17h40 quand les
premiers blessés sont évacués
devant la station saint-michel premières
images de gens visiblement très choquée
parce qu'ils viennent de vivre
[Musique]
dès les premières minutes de l'attentât
un poste médical avancé est installé
dans les bars situés juste à côté du
métro saint michel
selon les premières informations il y
aurait des blessés parmi les passagers
du rer mais également parmi les piétons
qu'ils aient circulé à ce moment là aux
abords de la place saint michel à cette
heure toutes les ambulances de paris et
de sa banlieue sont mobilisés et pour
l'instant certains blessés sont toujours
soignés sur la voie publique selon les
pompiers
la déflagration aurait testé très
importante et l'explosion aurait eu lieu
à peu près au milieu de la ram commencé
l'évacuation des victimes il nous
restait trois victimes incarcérées
nous sommes en train dé dégager dans le
wagon sinon l'ensemble des autres
victimes sont prises en charge par les
équipes médicales du samu et la brigade
des sapeurs-pompiers de paris sur les
lieux combien de personnes combien de
personnes sont ici des foyers ya au
moins 200 personnes entre deux et trois
cents personnes sur les lieux les
sapeurs-pompiers plus samuel faut
compter entre 3 400 personnes
dès les premières minutes de l'attentât
les victimes sont tenus à l'écart des
journalistes pendant ce temps dans le
métro interdit à la presse
des chirurgiens se voit obligé de
procéder à des amputations à l'extérieur
ce qui était loin de l'explosion et qui
ne sont pas blessés commencent à
raconter ce qu'ils ont vu ce qu'ils ont
entendus
il ya une grosse et rag ration est très
forte et du souffle je pense que ça
s'est passé dans la voiture derrière moi
il n'y a pas eu trop de panique les gens
sont sortis comme ça il ya eu beaucoup
de fumée
je suis revenu sur mes pas pour pourvoir
ce qui s'était passé il ne vous en veux
qu mais bon je crois qu'elle beaucoup de
victimes de gens quitter assez
grièvement blessé et puis tu vois la
chose les gens sans aider à s'aider les
uns les autres et tout ça fait un peu
faux quoi c'est comme si ce débat pour
de vrai mais mes fans je suis sur ma
lancée pour de vrai quoi on sait pas
exactement d'où elle est venue
l'explosion on était dans les voitures
donc ce que je sais c'est clé la
déflagration s'est produite vers
l'intérieur de la voiture puisque toutes
les vitres ont explosé à l'intérieur de
la voiture
et puis on va presser la scène d'horreur
[Musique]
et des blessés partout monsieur qu'est
ce que vous avez vu enfin moi j'étais
sur le quai en benne les wagons de tête
et j'ai vu une boule de feu à peu près 2
mètres 50 au dessus du au dessus du sol
sur l'arrière de la rame
enfin ça m'a paru sur l'arrière de la
rame au dessus du quai donc il ya eu
beaucoup de le mouvement de personnes
tout de suite en fumée est arrivé
lentement qu'après s'épaissit énormément
tous les blessés sont actuellement
orientées vers les hôpitaux de paris et
de banlieue
équipés de services de pathologie grave
certains ont été évacués par hélicoptère
c'est la section antiterroriste du
parquet de paris qui a été chargé de
cette enquête et selon certains
spécialistes voient avec certitude
l'hypothèse d'un attentat je propose de
retrouver tout de suite en direct des
lieux du drame claude son père l'autre
sens
vous constatez avec moi nous avons un
problème de liaison sont d'imaginer bien
la complexité de travailler sur les
lieux du drame
actuellement il ya évidemment énormément
de médias beaucoup de monde et il faut
évidemment surtout pas gêner le travail
des sauveteurs et des pompiers qui sont
viens de vous le montrer très très
rapide et très efficace sur les lieux de
cet attentat donc sans doute et qui a
fait je vous rappelle à quatre morts une
quarantaine de blessés
donc on 16 grave est ce que l'on peut
retenter la liaison et que claude son
père et qui est sur place et qui a
peut-être d'autres hypothèses à nous
donner sur cet attentat qui signe que
non je vous rappelle que jacques chirac
a est arrivée vers 19h30 il ya une demi
heure environ sur les lieux de cet
attentat ainsi que alain juppé pose
maintenant de retrouver et clôt son père
je pense que la liaison son ire et
habite l'aude
écoutez nous sommes donc en direct
depuis la place saint-michel ici il ya
beaucoup d'émotion pour le moment c'est
la priorité aux secours depuis 17h30
cette place saint michel a été interdite
à la circulation vous l'imaginez elle
était transformée en hôpital de campagne
toutes les minutes toutes les quelques
minutes un hélicoptère qui vient pour
évacuer les blessés
la plupart des blessés le dernier bilan
tout d'abord donc quatre morts et une
soixantaine de blessés dont une dizaine
seraient dans un état critique
la plupart des blessés se trouve encore
actuellement sur place
mise à part les blessés très graves qui
ont été évacués par hélicoptère il ya
beaucoup de blessés qui se trouvent
encore sur place qui ont été transportés
dans un café tout proche qui a été
transformé en véritable hôpital de
campagne alors tout ce qu'on sait pour
le moment d'après les premiers
témoignages de blessés vous avez écouté
dans le reportage de maryse burgot donc
vers 17h30 dans ce rer une explosion
très très forte apparemment dans la
dernière voiture du rer une explosion
suivie d'un incendie dans les premières
minutes quand nous sommes arrivés sur
place évidemment personne ne
confirmaient la thèse de l'attentât
mais à l'heure où je vous parle
apparemment monsieur juppé le premier
ministre qui s'est déplacé sur place a
lui même parlé d'un attentat
les juges antiterroristes au premier
rang desquels le monsieur bruguière est
actuellement sur place et de nombreux
magistrats du parquet de la section
anti-terroriste sont actuellement sur
place et les enquêteurs au milieu des
secouristes assez étrange commence
évidemment leur enquête et nous n'avons
pour le moment aucune précision sur
cette explosion
mais en tous les cas la plupart des
blessés parle d'une explosion
extrêmement forts qui s'est produite à
l'arrière du rer suivi donc d'un
incendie la plupart des blessés ont été
soufflées pris dans le souffle des
explosions la plupart des blessés que
nous avons vus ne portait plus leurs
vêtements et sont donc actuellement
soigné par l'ensemble des secouristes
ici sur place
je rappelle le dernier bilan pour le
moment quatre morts et une soixantaine
de blessés dont 10 dans un état critique
et les opérations de secours à l'heure
où je vous parle se poursuivre il y aura
encore trois personnes incarcérées dans
le rer et les pompiers effectivement
essaye d'approcher pour le moment ces
personnes
merci claude son père dans un instant
les reportages de nous autres envoyés
spéciaux sur l'île ce drame encore une
fois on vous l'a dit
la thèse de l'attentât n'est pas
confirmée expressément à l'heure où nous
parlons ce qui s'est passé cet après
midi à la station saint-michel du revers
rappelle en tout cas cependant les
attentats qui ont endeuillé paris de
décembre 85 à septembre 86 eric lemasson
c'était au temps où la france vivait
dans l'angoissé des attentats
terroristes septembre 86 en 13 jours six
attentats vont frapper la capitale
ici à la défense dans la cafétéria du
supermarché casino au centre commercial
des quatre temps une bombe explose à
l'heure du déjeuner 41 blessés le jour
plus tard c'est en plein coeur de paris
sur les champs elysées dans les sous
sols du pub renault une bombe tue deux
policiers les français connaissent alors
par coeur les initiales du groupe
terroriste qui revendiquent ces
attentats cs ppa comité de solidarité
avec les prisonniers politiques arabes
des bombes pour obtenir la libération de
georges ibrahim abdallah et anis
naccache détenus en france
bureau de poste préfecture de police ce
sont parfois les symboles de l'état
français qui sont visés alors que
jacques chirac ait premier ministre de
la première car habitations mais c'est
aussi la rue la foule anonyme qui sera
visé les terroristes veulent frapper
l'opinion le 17 septembre rue de rennes
une charge explose devant le magasin
tati
l'attentât le plus meurtrier cinq morts
et plus de 40 blessés à cette époque une
psychose de l'attentât s'était emparée
des français cinémas restaurants lieux
publics se vider une peur qui se
manifestera à nouveau au moment de la
guerre du golfe
pourtant depuis l'automne 86 jamais la
france ne sera frappé à nouveau
par un attentat terroriste de l'ampleur
de celui d'aujourd'hui
s'il s'agit effectivement d'un attentat
la cible était bien trouver en effet des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
parisiens utilisent chaque jour les
lignes du rer
l'explication précision les eaux
lamberton le rer réseau express régional
c'est le moyen de transport du
banlieusard parisien gérer en partie par
la ratp la sncf
il a été créé à la fin des années 60
lorsque sont apparus les villes
nouvelles
aux alentours de paris 400 km de réseau
réparti en quatre lignes principales
sillonne toute l'ile-de-france tout
traverse aussi paris la ligne b sur
laquelle s'est produite l'explosion fut
un axe nord-sud c'est celle qui dessert
l'aéroport de roissy on était quatre
cent mille personnes l'empruntent chaque
jour et vous heures de pointe il ya près
de 25 mille voyageurs la station saint
michel est un centre de trafic intense
au coeur de paris s'y croisent deux
lignes de rer et de lignes de métro
cinquante mille personnes y passent
chaque jour environ 10000 aux heures de
pointe ce qui était le cas au moment de
l'explosion
pour les mesures de sécurité il existe
des caméras de surveillance sur les
quais la ratp la sncf ont leur propre
service d'ordre et depuis la vague
d'attentats de 1986 il existe une
brigade de policiers affectés
spécialement au réseau jacques chirac
que je vous le disais s'est rendu sur
les lieux de ce drame ainsi qu'alain
juppé qui a tenu à s'incliner devant la
mémoire des victimes
témoignez de la sollicitude du
gouvernement aux blessés également
rendre hommage à la vitesse
d'intervention des secours je vous
propose de retrouver claude son père qui
est sur place
écoutez par le moment effectivement
jacques chirac de très nombreuses
personnalités sont arrivés en tête le
président de la république qui arrivé
ici à peu près 20 minutes et avant lui
était arrivé monsieur thibault que
monsieur tiberi pardon le maire de paris
monsieur sy tiberi qui a pu grâce au
préfet 2 avec le préfet de police
décembre dans l'enceinte du rer est ce
le seul actuellement qui a pu descendre
et voir effectivement ce qui s'était
passé dans les erreurs
voilà je vous propose de vous retrouver
dans quelques minutes merci claude son
père je vous propose de découvrir
maintenant le reportage que viennent de
nous faire parvenir
anne consigny qui elle aussi était sur
les lieux de cet attentat qui a fait je
me rappelle qu'à pneus
istres alain juppé le ministre des
transports bernard pons et le maire de
paris jean tiberi se sont rendus sur les
lieux place saint michel
ils sont entrés dans le café qui fait
l'angle avec lequel le café qui a été
transformé en poste médical avancé où
sont traitées quatre blessés graves des
blessés légers et où sont examinées
également toutes les personnes qui se
trouvaient dans le rer au moment de
l'explosion
si beaucoup ça c'est une vente explosion
sais pas d'où est l'origine il avait
nommément de fumée les gens sont sortis
très rapidement la patrouille de de
panique mais il ya eu beaucoup
d'inconvénients dus à la fumée les gens
de passer par les fenêtres et les ceux
qui ont eu beaucoup de chance et la tête
de durham cette jeune fille qui s'en
aller sans dommage devra elle aussi
passer par le poste médical avancé
indépendamment de ce lieu un autre point
de secours a été installé en bas dans la
station rer à haut niveau
c'est suite à l'intervention deuxième
sous-sol du rer est actuellement à ce
niveau là en bilan provisoire nous avons
sept blessés extrêmement graves qui sont
des blessés des cribles un des blast et
des amputés de trois décédés alors nous
parlons il reste encore des blessés dans
les cafés du départ saint michel et du
saint séverin trois heures après
l'explosion qui a secoué la gare rer
voisine
la taille qui ont arrêté nani carrick
nous reviendrons bien sûr dans le
courant de ce journal sur cet attentat
donc dans le rer à paris à la station
saint-michel qui je vous rappelle au
dernier bilan a fait quatre morts et 16
blessés graves
l'autre actualité tout aussi dramatique
l'aggravation de la situation en bosnie
où les casques bleus français ont rendu
aujourd'hui un dernier hommage aux deux
officiers tués samedi soir par
l'artillerie serbe françois cornut
soldats de la paix officier français
abattus sur noise mans à sarajevo alors
que l'un escortaient un convoi
humanitaire à destination des assiégés
de la capitale bosniaque et que le
second était en faction dans son poste
d'observation des nations unies au match
de leur régiment et de leur chef
commandant les casques bleus dans la
capitale bosniaque de ces morts-là aussi
les leaders politiques et militaires des
serbes de bosnie pourrait un jour
répondre le tribunal pénal international
de la haye les a mis officiellement en
accusation pour génocide et crimes
contre l'humanité à l'encontre de la
population musulmane et croate de bosnie
et pour avoir abattu ou utiliser les
casques bleus comme boucliers humains
propose de revenir à l'attentât de la
station saint-michel cet après midi à
paris
attentat qui a fait quatre morts et 16
blessés graves avec les images de
jacques chirac le présent de la
république qui s'est rendu sur les lieux
tout à l'heure j'espère que nous allons
voir ces images
voilà jacques chirac qui avait dû
affronter les circonstances tout aussi
dramatique lorsqu'il avait été nommé
premier ministre en 86 le soir même de
sa nomination avec une explosion de
grammatiko points chauds sur les champs
elysées qui avait fait également
plusieurs victimes voyez jacques chirac
en compagnie d'un juppé deux fois
ministre et du maire de paris jean
tiberi
tout de suite nous retrouvons clos de
son père sur place tout allait donc les
toutes dernières informations
effectivement quatre morts le bilan qui
est donnée ici au niveau des blessés
beaucoup plus élevé puisqu'on parle
d'une soixantaine de blessés une dizaine
dans un état grave
ici on est donc toujours dans une phase
d'urgence puisque le plan rouge a été
déclenché immédiatement apprécié et
explosions par le préfet de police sur
paris vers 17h30
le plan rouge ce qui signifie la
mobilisation générale des secours
actuellement il ya plus de 300 pompiers
sur place assister par des équipes du
samu un café à quelques dizaines de
mètres derrière moi était transformée en
hôpital de guerre on peut dire puisque
actuellement des opérations de saumur
gens sont pratiquées dans ce café et la
plupart des blessés que nous avons pu
voir donc souffrent de brûlures
puisqu'il était pris dans le souffle
d'une explosion extrêmement violente
donc pour le moment les secours se
poursuivent je vous disais tout à
l'heure et secours tentent toujours de
death incarcéré trois personnes qui se
trouvent encore prise dans cette rame du
rer pour le moment aucun journaliste n'a
pu évidemment décembre dans ce rer qui
se trouve juste à quelques dizaines de
mètres derrière moi il s'agit de la
ligne b du rer en direction de saint
rémy les chevreuse et c'est une rame qui
rentrait dans la station saint-michel
lorsqu'une explosion très violente s'est
produite apparemment à l'arrière du
train puisque la plupart des témoignages
que vous avez pu entendre et et des
blessés légers qui se trouvaient à
l'avant du train donc pour le moment
toujours une phase d'urgence la
mobilisation des secours et jacques
chirac serait encore actuellement sur
place merci que son père je pose de
revenir à la situation en bosnie avec ce
soir un élément nouveau
le leader des serbes bosniaques radovan
karadzic qui son bras droit le général
le râteau mattich commandant de l'armée
serbe bosniaque ont été inculpé
aujourd'hui de génocide de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité
cela par le tribunal criminel des
nations unies les responsables des
nations unies sur place sont toujours
sans aucune nouvelle
d'environ 7000 habitants de l'enclavé
musulmane de srebrenica tombée aux mains
des serbes il ya maintenant deux
semaines
le rapporteur spécial des nations unies
pour les droits de l'homme le polonais
maclou et si affirme tenir des
informations précises sur des crimes
horribles commis par les serbes
thierry thuillier radovan karadzic le
politique et ratko mladic le militaire
voici les deux principaux accusés serbe
une liste qui en compte 24 inculpé de
génocide et de crimes contre l'humanité
l'acte d'accusation est aussi long que
grave il aurait reproché à eux et aux
milices qu'il dirige notamment
l'encerclement de sarajevo et son
cortège de massacres d'assassinats de
civils tués par les obus ou les balles
des tireurs cern mais ils sont également
accusés d'être les organisateurs de
l'épuration ethnique en bosnie comme
dernièrement à srebrenica
le bilan est éloquent 23 mille réfugiés
sept mille disparus
l'épuration c'était aussi il y a trois
ans la découverte des camps de détention
serbes des mouroirs dont les images
renvoyait l'europe 50 ans en arrière
à tout ceci la n a encore ajouté un
dernier chef d'inculpation
la prise d'otages il y a quelques
semaines des casques bleus ratko mladic
qui jouait encore ces derniers jours au
général magnanime devant les réfugiés
musulmans de srebrenica et radovan
karadzic savent désormais ce que la
justice internationale leur reproche de
mandats d'arrêts viennent d'ailleurs
d'être lancé
mais avec bien peu de chance d'être
exécutée tant que l'onu continuera de
les considérer comme des interlocuteurs
incontournables
nous avons vu tout à l'heure des images
de la levée du corps des officiers
français tués samedi soir à sarajevo et
c'est précisément pour dissuader les
milices serbes de bosnie de s'en prendre
à nouveau aux casques bleus
environ 800 soldats français et
britanniques de la force de réaction
rapide sont en train de se déployer sur
le mont igman sur les hauteurs de
sarajevo
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
dorothée olliéric alain dumas et pascal
perrin
chaque française et anglaise sur les
mêmes pistes du mont igman le
déploiement des troupes de la force de
réaction rapide s'est poursuivie toute
la journée
officiellement tout s'est bien déroulé
dans les collines de sarajevo chars
véhicules blindés
nick fry aux formes est un ballet
menaçant à quelques kilomètres des
positions serbes
on aurait cru les soldats préparant une
offensive au loin les obus a explosé
mais les militaires n'entendait que les
coûts et il attendait les ordres nous
sommes maintenant prêts à nous battre le
préparons nos munitions nous finissons
trancher les positions de l'article
nous installons les derniers sacs de
sable pour la protection de nos hommes
et une 6e position de ravir les
tranchées les deux frères s'étaient
effectivement l'activité principale de
la journée pour les militaires
britanniques
la mission a beau être limitée à 5 jours
ils s'installent sur will ohman on ne
sait jamais et puis il faut bien cacher
les d'armes mais aussi où chez les
hommes un peu plus loin
le programme était différent ici c'est
un exercice pour répondre aux éventuels
tirs serbe le matériel et sophistiquée
les observateurs repère la position de
l'attaquant il n'y a plus qu à riposter
cet après midi des soldats bosniaques
sont passés devant ce long cortège de
chars il était un peu étonné un peu
sceptique possible quant aux militaires
français des britanniques il se disait
restons nous ici comme nask où allons
nous battre
si la puissance de feu des forces
franco-britanniques est importante elle
reste tout de même limité mais il ne
s'agit pas de faire la guerre aux serbes
et c'est sans doute pour cela que la
moitié du contingent britannique est
retourné à sa base
ici à vitez mais le haut commandement
britannique nous assurent qu'ils sont
prêts à repartir au kazoo cette force de
réaction rapide dépend du commandement
de la forpronu les occidentaux sont
divisés sur le problème dit de la double
clé à savoir de la décision commune
d'une intervention armée de l'otan et de
l'onu bill clinton et jacques chirac en
ont discuté au téléphone hier alors que
les ambassadeurs de l'otan réunis à
bruxelles semble piétiner
autre élément politique important le
sénat américain devrait discuter dans
les toutes prochaines heures de la
proposition des républicains
majoritaires au sénat d'une levée
unilatérale de l'embargo sur les
livraisons d'armes aux bosniaques à
washington pour front
de philippe rochot les sénateurs
américains se retrouvent cette fois pour
voter la levée de l'embargo sur les
armes à destination de la bosnie bill
clinton avait réussi à faire plier le
sénateur dole en obtenant qu'ils
reculent ce vote d'une semaine afin de
ne pas compromettre les résultats de la
conférence de long si le vote passent à
une majorité des deux tiers la maison
blanche ne pourra pas s'y opposer
et c'est ce qui se dessine car les
sénateurs sont harcelés par les groupes
de pression religieux juifs et musulmans
qui lui demande de lever l'embargo sur
les armes à destination de la bosnie
nous sommes très encouragés par ce qu'a
dit le président chirac mais nous avons
besoin de plus la simple levée de
l'embargo ne nous aide pas suffisamment
nous avons besoin d'une action rapide
d'une intervention dont le président
chirac pourrait prendre la tête en
coopération avec le président clinton
pour arrêter l'agression
cette amérique qui veut renforcer son
dispositif aérien sur la bosnie est
bloquée l'offensive des serbes auraient
bien aimé se passer du feu vert de l'onu
dont la lourdeur bloque toute décision
militaire et passer outre le système de
double cle otan onu
qu'il s'agisse des frappes aériennes ou
qu'il s'agisse de la levée de l'embargo
sur les armes à destination de la bosnie
l'amérique ne pourra faire appliquer ses
propres décisions qu'avec l'accord des
nations unies et donc le feu vert de la
communauté internationale et washington
et bien condamné à respecter le système
de la double clé ou moins pour les
frappes aériennes d'envergure propose de
revenir tout de suite sur l'attentât qui
a endeuillé paris cet après midi quatre
morts et une vingtaine de blessés graves
dans le métro parisien a tout de suite
le commentaire du porte parole des
sapeurs pompiers de paris
il y avait les personnes encore
achevée très dans les ferrailles et il a
fallu tout de suite mettre en oeuvre des
équipes médicales pour se couvrir les
premières victimes gravement atteinte
polycriblé voire même des membres
sectionnés
puis avec catégoriser en urgence pour
les évacués sur les hôpitaux de cette
une action principalement médicale qui a
pu être menée à bien grâce au blanc
rouge qui est maintenant le bien commun
est ce qu'on peut parler d'une explosion
criminelle
l'aspect criminel de l'explosion n'est
pas du ressort des pompiers mais c'est
vraiment une explosion qui s'est situé
dans la voiture de numéro 6 j'ai pas mal
comportés vite
vous revenez les concours besoin du pois
rouges du genre ou par le plan rouge est
une action qui consiste à ramener sur
les lieux de l'accident un homme très
importante de moyens non médicalisés
cinq médecins et de moyens médicalisé
avec médecins pompiers de paris et des
médecins du samu de façon à pouvoir
si vous voulez intégrer sort transporté
à l'hôpital vers les victimes en
dénonçant à éviter que leurs attentes
leur état ne s'aggrave vante d'ailleurs
où sont installés ces plots médicaux des
points musicaux étaient installés au
deuxième sous-sol sur le plus juste
voilà voilà oui
ici au barca derrière nos moyens on a
évacué les blessés qu'on vient d'être
arrêté que le actuellement c'est
quasiment fini
la plus libre du puits mamba oui parce
qu'ils combattent ces dispositifs et à
tous les blessés ont été évacués par
hélicoptère non deux seuls les plus
graves ont été évacués par hélicoptère
l'évacuation des blessés consiste à
transporter plusieurs blessés dans les
véhicules non médicalisés ensuite les
blessés graves dans les habits de
réanimation des pompiers du samu
dans les cas extrêmes paiva comment vous
décrire la situation va vous propose
maintenant de retrouver là nos envoyés
spéciaux sur les lieux de ce drame
claude son père claude entendu la
prudence de ce porte-parole des pompiers
effectivement je veux dire il est il
faut rester très prudent actuellement il
ya une très forte explosion dans ce rer
évidemment tout le monde pense à un
attentat l'heure de pointe 17h30
beaucoup de monde dans le rer
tout le monde reste très prudent mais
évidemment tout le monde pensait à un
attentat à la preuve la plupart des
magistrats antiterroristes sont sur
place le juge bruguière de nombreux
magistrats du parquet même s'il reste
prudent
des experts sont actuellement sur place
et essayent de déterminer la nature de
cette explosion je vous propose tout de
suite de voir un reportage de pascal
douce est bon et bernard puis sow sur
l'organisation des secours ici place
saint michel en moins de dix minutes
c'est tout le quartier autour de la
place saint michel qui a été bouclé un
mot d'ordre les séro secours qui
s'activent en sous sol la plus grande
marge de manoeuvre possible en bloquant
journalistes et badauds en surface il a
fallu également dans l'un des quartiers
les plus fréquentées de paris en été
mais n'agir une place aux hélicoptères
selon l'un des plans d'urgence répéter
régulièrement par les pompiers et la
sécurité civile ainsi l'évacuation des
blessés encore transportable se fait
dans le calme à quelques mètres de là
alain juppé bernard pons et jean tiberi
arriver vers 18h30 sont venus constater
l'étendue des dégâts et secours médicaux
sont encore loin d'avoir fini leur
travail
voilà écoutez donc beaucoup d'émotions
ici place saint michel les secours se
poursuivent actuellement puisqu'il ya
encore des personnes qui se trouve
incarcéré dans cette rame de rer
je lisais il faut rester prudent pour le
moment évidemment tout le monde pense à
un attentat il ya une très forte
explosion mais prudents pour le moment
la priorité est au score puisque les
opérations se poursuivent où vous
l'entendez peut-être un hélicoptère
actuellement qui vient de se poser
l'hélicoptère se pose régulièrement peu
près de l'église notre dame
pour évacuer les blessés je vous
rappelle le dernier bilan que nous
devons nous disposons pour le moment
quatre morts et une soixantaine de
blessés dont 10 seraient dans un état
critique
merci jean michel carpentier une civile
de crise est actuellement réuni au
ministère de l'intérieur
oui le ministre de l'intérieur jean
louis debré qui était en déplacement
vient d'annoncer le renforcement de la
surveillance des bâtiments et des lieux
publics des transports en commun et plus
généralement de tous les lieux de grande
affluence est également le renforcement
des contrôles dans les aéroports et aux
frontières alors selon l'elysée que nous
venons de joindre il n'y avait aucune
inquiétude particulière à craindre en ce
moment en matière de terrorisme pour
l'instant aucune piste n'est privilégiée
on peut simplement observé qu'il y a
quinze jours s'était produit le premier
attentat sur le sol français lié à la
situation algérienne avec le meurtre
d'un fondateur du fils le shaq sahraouis
devant la mosquée du xviiie à paris
faut-il repenser au détournement de
l'airbus d'air france en décembre
dernier et faut-il alors se tourner vers
les islamistes algériens du gia
ce serait prématuré on peut également
mentionner la venue de yasser arafat
demain à paris le leader palestinien qui
arrivent dans notre pays au lendemain du
terrible attentat du mouvement hamas à
tel aviv en israël faut-il également
penser à la situation en bosnie alors
que l'on parlait d'un bombardement par
un avion français sur palais la capitale
bosno serbes dimanche dernier
bombardement formellement démentie par
paris mais de toute façon un seul mot
s'impose la prudence une enquête très
difficile a déjà commencé et au moment
où je vous parle il n'y a encore aucune
revendication officielle
on peut simplement rappelé que déjà en
1986 à peine arrivée à matignon jacques
chirac avait dû se rendre à la galerie
points chauds sur les champs-elysées à
paris un attentat qui avait été commis
par des terroristes à l'époque liés à
l'iran mais cette fois à peine élu à
l'elysée le président de la république
va devoir gérer une situation difficile
un attentat à paris en plein été fait
pour tuer le plus grand nombre fait pour
blesser la france merci jean michel
carpentier nous l'avons dit le président
jacques chirac s'est rendu immédiatement
sur les lieux de cet attentat à la
station saint-michel du rer de paris
attentats donc qui a fait quatre morts
et 16 blessés graves dans le voir les
images du chef de l'état qui
s'entretient avec
les sauveteurs bien sûr et puis aussi
des responsables politiques
les magistrats les responsables de la
cellule anti-terroriste qui ont commencé
l'enquète nous retrouverons en fin de
journal nous envoyés spéciaux bien
évidemment sur ce drame
auparavant je vous propose de prendre
connaissance des autres informations de
ce mardi est tout d'abord cette visite
du juge halphen à matignon le juge a été
reçue à la résidence du premier ministre
pour s'informer sur la réglementation en
vigueur concernant les fouilles secret
en effet le juge qui perquisitionné hier
au siège du parti républicain a
découvert dans le coffre du trésorier du
p r jean pierre thomas 2 millions 400
mille francs en billets de 500 francs
provenant précisément de ces fameux
fonds secrets tout le problème est de
savoir si ces fonds étaient destinés au
financement de la campagne d'edouard
balladur
la loi interdit en effet formellement
tout don ou financement un parti
politique par une personne morale de
droit public en quête michèle fines
alain juppé a pris l'événement
suffisamment au sérieux pour faire
intervenir le porte-parole du
gouvernement le juge halphen s'est bien
rendu à matignon il a été reçu par le
chef de cabinet du premier ministre
mais ces questions viser les activités
de l'ancien gouvernement aurait été
l'intérêt du juge halphen portait sur
les déclarations jean pierre thomas
lauria du côté républicain sur les
crédits sont alloués au premier ministre
qui sont des crédits qui sont votés dans
le cadre de la loi de finances et les
questions du juge halphen porté
principalement sur ses crédits
ces deux concerts naturellement ni de
près ni de loin ni un directement ni
indirectement
l'actuel gouvernement
s'il est rapide il était important de le
rappeler en perquisitionnant jeudi
dernier dans le bureau de jean pierre
thomas le juge halphen a découvert dans
le coffre fort 2 millions 400 mille
francs en coupures de 500 francs aux
magistrats qui s'étonnait de voir tant
d'argent en espèces jean pierre thomas a
expliqué qu'il s'agissait de fonds
secrets versé par matignon pendant la
dernière campagne présidentielle
cet argent at il dit devait financer le
parti républicain et en particulier les
sénateurs du tr pour jean-pierre thomas
tout est légal pourtant la loi sur le
financement politique est formel les
personnes morales de droit public ne
peuvent effectuer aucun don à une
association ou un mandataire de partis
politiques même avec des fonds secrets
c'est pour tout dire une pratique
ancienne et bien connu sa légitimité
c'est au peuple de l'apprécier quant à
sa légalité
là c'est le seul point qui me paraît
pouvoir être clair il existe une
prohibition légal du financement des
partis politiques par des fonds publics
comme il n'est pas saisie du financement
du parti républicain
le juge halphen a laissé les deux
millions quatre dans le coffre du
trésorier pourtant jean-pierre thomas
sera obligé de prouver l'origine de cet
argent
les anciens locataires de l'hôtel
matignon devront s'expliquer ce matin le
parti républicain a préféré préciser que
ces deux millions quatre n'ont aucun
lien ni de près ni de loin avec une
campagne présidentielle maigre
consolation pour les contribuables
grincheux ailleurs vous seriez beaucoup
plus maltraitée encore c'est ce qui
ressort d'un rapport sur le système
fiscal français commandé par le
précédent gouvernement tenu secret et
qui a été rendue publique par alain
madelin le poids de l'impôt sur le
revenu est en effet faible en france 6%
du produit intérieur brut contre 12% en
moyenne dans les pays de l' ocde
en revanche le poids des cotisations
sociales est beaucoup plus lourd en
france qu'à l'étranger
yannick letranchant la boue fiscale
aujourd'hui c'est une spécificité bien
de chez nous un prélèvement peut en
cacher un autre
certes la part de l'impôt sur le revenu
est en france plus faible que chez nos
voisins les ménages les plus modestes
en fait la moitié des contribuables en
sont dispensés seulement voilà ces
foyers les plus modestes sont en même
temps les plus touchés par les
cotisations sociales
résultat selon le rapport du camin le
système fiscal français est
particulièrement injuste c'est bien
pourquoi ce rapport préconise une
clarification une remise à plat la csg
plus juste parce que proportionnelle aux
revenus pourraient être relevées en
contrepartie d'une baisse des
cotisations sociales
le gouvernement a publié ce rapport
aujourd'hui tout en prenant ses
distances
il faut dire que dans une semaine la tva
passe de 18,6 à 20,6 pour cent une
mesure qui frappe davantage les ménages
les plus modestes et selon une autre
étude menée celle là par les experts de
la commission européenne de bruxelles le
prix des voitures neuves peu varié en
europe jusqu'à 55 % en moyenne les
écarts sont de 20% d'un pays à l'autre
de l'union européenne reste reste à
faire homologuer les voitures achetées à
l'étranger par le service des mines
enquête
alban nicosie et céline qu une renault
19 40% moins chers en italie - 30 % pour
une peugeot 306 voilà qui fait bondir
les concessionnaires des alpes-maritimes
chez peugeot par exemple on admet une
perte de 5 % des clients cette année
mais on espère que la tendance va
s'inverser les prix des voitures
italiennes ont remonté et aujourd'hui
cette différence de tarif et je le
répète moins intéressante pour le
consommateur
renault comme peugeot ont en effet
décidé au début du mois de rééquilibrer
le marché après l'écoulement des stocks
actuels et sauf exception
ce sera donc la fin des voitures
largement moins cher en italie côté
transalpin à 40 kilomètres seulement de
la les concessionnaires sont discrets
sur le nombre exact de clients français
a tiré au prix de la voiture
s'ajoute ici une taxe d'un million de
livres soit près de 3000 francs
l'économie moyenne réalisée donc proche
de 10% du prix de vente assez pour
tenter quelques petits malins
on nous vend donc seulement des
véhicules aux clients individuels qui se
présentent ici en italie
vous ne vendez pas ou mandataires n'ont
absolument pas aujourd'hui me lire ne
représentent plus que 3 francs ces
dévaluations successives sont une
aubaine pour le pouvoir d'achat des
étrangers en italie
mais attention les concessionnaires
français propose te souvent des reprises
et autres remises qui ne sont pas
pratiqués ailleurs retour au drame de
cet après-midi l'explosion dans le rural
la station saint michel sont propose de
découvrir tout de suite le reportage de
maryse burgot en plein centre de paris
des dizaines de gens choqués blessés
il était 17h30 ce soir quand l'explosion
s'est produite
c'était à l'intérieur de la station
saint-michel dans une rame de rer
station très touristique c'était une
heure d'affluence
à ce moment là ils étaient nombreux dans
le rer
[Musique]
d'après les premiers bilans quatre
personnes sont décédées
plusieurs dizaines d'autres sont
grièvement blessés à l' acte pompiers
médecins et infirmières ont installé
leur poste médical avancé dans le bar
situé juste à côté de la station
saint-michel et pompiers ont déclenché
le plan rouge
le samu à déclencher le plan blanc se
font en fait toutes les ambulances de
paris et de sa banlieue qui sont à ce
moment mobiliser tous les blessés sont
évacués vers les hôpitaux équipés de
services de pathologie grave
[Musique]
d'autres vont tout de suite en direct
octobre son père qui à ses côtés des
responsables des équipes de secours
je vous propose de faire tout de suite
un point sur la situation actuellement
la station saint-michel à mes côtés le
colonel alain michel vous avez dirigé
les opérations de secours au niveau des
pompiers quel est le dernier bilan que
vous avez ou est ce qu'on en a
actuellement
alors actuellement toutes les victimes
ont été évacuées sur les hôpitaux
il y a quatre décédés 14 urgence absolue
et 47 blessés plus légers toutes ces
personnes ont été prises en charge par
une vingtaine d' équipe médicalisée de
la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
et du samu donc justement un peu à vos
côtés le principal responsable du samu
sur place est ce que vous pouvez dire
vous êtes descendu en bas vous avez
travaillé sur cette rame de rer vous
avez évacuer les blessés
à quoi ça ressemble si vous me permettez
la question en bas c'est quoi qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en bas il est difficile
de décrire la situation
c'est une explosion tout à fait grave il
ya de très nombreuses victimes et à
l'heure actuelle la situation est
totalement maîtrisé toutes les victimes
ont été évacuées pour l'instant
et ces victimes sont fiers charge dans
les hôpitaux de l'assistance publique
le plan blanc hospitalier qui permet
d'accueillir de très nombreuses victimes
a été déclenché et elles sont toutes
entre les mains des équipes spécialisées
à l'heure actuelle ni aucun problème
quant à l'hospitalisation de ses
victimes pour ce qui est de l'état donc
et des premiers intervenants la
situation a été très dur mais en moins
de deux heures elle était totalement
contrôlé toutes les victimes évacuées
par des moyens médicalisé dans les
meilleures conditions techniques que
l'on peut avoir dans ce domaine aussi
votre premier commentaire sur vous êtes
descendu en bas vous avez vu cette rame
de rer à part moi c'est une rame qui
étaient à quai et c'est ça qui est ça
michel dans cette station de rer
une explosion très forte apparemment
mieux d'aram c'est ça voilà une des
extrémités d'un wagon trois personnes
ont été trouvées déchiqueté un certain
nombre d'autres personnes ont été
trouvées dans un état extrêmement grave
et dans une dans un premier temps sept
personnes ont été médicalisées
immédiatement au niveau de ce deuxième
sous sol et un deuxième poste médical
avancé a été établi au niveau de la
surface et donc l'ensemble des moyens du
plan rouge ont été mis en place et il
faut noter que des gestes médicaux
extrêmement importants ont été
pratiquées les pompiers immédiatement
sur place on triait examiner ses
victimes et on a fait pratiquement une
classification ces pratiques mandat
chirurgie de guerre et de la réanimation
de guerre colonna je sais que c'est pas
le domaine mais vous avez l'expérience
de ce type de catastrophe
un attentat une explosion très forte
vous avez une idée apparemment il s'agit
quand même d'une explosion par un engin
explosif extrêmement puissant
maintenant en tant que médecin je ne
m'avancerai pas si vous voulez sur les
problèmes plus technique et je crois
qu'il ya des officiers de pompiers qui
pourront vous répondre sur ce sujet
monsieur carli vous confirmez donc c'est
actuellement les opérations de secours
sont terminées
oui les victimes ont été toutes prises
en charge elles sont toutes évacuées
elles sont aux mains des hôpitaux
spécialisés de l'assistance publique
dont de ce point de vue là la situation
est maintenant totalement méprisé et
nous avons donc maintenant un bilan
quasi définitif de ce qui s'est passé
quatre morts 47 blessées dont 14 15 dans
un état critique ce sens dans un état
critique c'est exactement ça est donc
les hôpitaux de paris de la banlieue
parisienne dépendant de l'assistance
publique ont pris en charge toutes ces
victimes très rapidement
petit point si vous permettez je crois
que c'est important actuellement nous
sommes en train de faire une réunion et
d'ici quelques minutes
nous allons pouvoir dresser un listing
complet avec les identités des personnes
prises en charge par nos services et les
destinations hospitalière voilà voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire pour le moment
bruno si vous voulez bien encore un
petit point à mes côtés arrive
bonjour monsieur vous êtes le
responsable de la ratp est ce que vous
êtes descendu en bas qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que vous avez vu c'est un
c'est un vrai drame
et en ce moment notre pensée va
exclusivement vers les familles des
voyageurs mettant en place donc services
d'information à destination des
voyageurs d'un homme d'un point
d'accueil pour les mains numéro
téléphone déjà qu'on pourrait donner aux
familles des victimes c'est important
donc c'est le 36 68 77 14 d'entre eux 36
68 77 14 pour toutes les familles qui
veulent se renseigner au niveau des
blessés vous êtes descendus apparemment
je veux dire on parle d'une très forte
explosion vous avez déjà un commentaire
sur je n'ai pas de commentaires à faire
la police le préfet de police étaient
sur place le président de la république
était sur place
le premier ministre était sur place le
maire de paris et le président de la
ratp donc
un attentat la police vous informera des
suites et de l' enquête qui est en cours
voilà tout ce qu'on pouvait dire
actuellement sur ce qui s'est passé ici
dans cette station de rer
ici au niveau du métro saint-michel donc
je vous rappelle le bilan confirmé par
le colonel des pompiers il ya un instant
quatre morts 47 blessés dont 15 dans un
état critique
merci et je rappelle donc celui en
téléphone pour connaître l'identité des
victimes 36 68 77 14
on l'a dit tous les blessés sont
maintenant hospitalisées je vous propose
de retrouver
j'évite ambert en direct de l'hôtel dieu
oui si en effet beaucoup de camions de
pompiers et une ambulance du samu sont
arrivés depuis 18 heures car l'hôtel
dieu se trouva à peine 200 mètres des
lieux de l'explosion de la place saint
michel c'est en fait l'hôpital le plus
proche de la place saint-michel pourtant
la majorité des blessés ont reçu tout
d'abord les premiers soins sur les lieux
même de l'attentât où une structure
hospitalière avait été mis sur place et
en suisse qu'on peut dire c'est que la
majorité donc de ses blessés a été
orienté vers d'autres hôpitaux de la
région parisienne et de la capitale
d'autres hôpitaux qui dispose de
structures de pâtes pouvant accueillir
les pathologies lourdes ce qui n'est pas
le cas de l'hôtel dieu
l'hôtel dieu par exemple ne dispose pas
d'un service pouvant accueillir les
grands brûlés actuellement derrière moi
vous avez un hélicoptère qui va décoller
pour justement embarquer un blessé sans
doute sérieusement atteint vers un
hôpital car c'est ici le parvis de
l'église notre-dame et ce parvis de
l'église notre-dame sert depuis
maintenant une heure et demie de base de
décollage improvisé pour tous ces
hélicoptères que je peux vous dire aussi
c'est que j'ai vu
depuis maintenant une heure et demi
beaucoup de gens attendre inquiet ici
dans l'entrée des urgences de l'hôpital
de l'hôtel-dieu des personnes qui
attendent des nouvelles de proches
d'amis de parents qui auraient pu se
trouver vers 17h45 au métro saint michel
moment de l'attentât non merci j'habite
en bien pour ces précisions
je vous propose de prendre connaissance
des autres informations de ce jour et on
a frôlé la catastrophe hier soir du côté
de serre-chevalier ou deux hameaux ont
été envahies par de soudaines coulée de
boue consécutive un très violent orage
tout le monde heureusement a pu être
évacués à temps et l'on ne déplore que
cinq blessés reportage didier guyot fini
fini il ne faudra que quelques minutes
aux paisibles au ruisseau de base pour
se transformer en torrent de boue
dévastant tout sur son passage
gonflé par de violents orages de grêle
tombée là haut sur la montagne le
ruisseau sortir un soudain de son lit
emportant avec lui troncs d'arbres et
rochers
les rochers qui dévalait et surtout ce
bruit celui celui d'en faire les chocs
souffre d énormes galets qui passait
autour de la maison
fort heureusement ne compte que trois
blessés légers et si beaucoup
d'habitations ont été envahies par la
boue peu ont été détruites
quand le torrent se mettra dévalé la
montagne une centaine de villageois
auront le réflexe de quitter rapidement
leur maison un réflexe qui les sauvera
certains tenteront de combattre la boue
en vous moi j'avais six gamins guide et
là j'ai fait monter dernier étage s'est
essayé de bloquer la porte comme j'ai pu
et puis avec mon père mais c'est
d'éveiller derrière la porte a explosé
alors les deux voitures
elles sont parties il avait tout compris
c'est la mienne en tout cas atteindre
4,4 et puis à une audi dans le doctorant
et son 400 m haies en fait ici se tenait
un parking avec un abribus en quelques
instants tout sera submergé toute la
journée gendarmes secouristes et
militaires ont déblayé colmater nettoyer
une aide appréciée par des habitants
n'oublie pas que c'est la troisième fois
en un siècle que le baise c'est entendre
sa voix
l'actualité est ainsi fait que nous
allons maintenant parler d'athlétisme
cela à quelques jours du championnat du
monde en suède ce soir lors d'un meeting
à monaco et marie josé pérec eux
participé au 400 m avec l'espoir de
descendre en dessous des 50 secondes at
elle tenu à ce paris vous propose
d'entendre le commentaire de patrick
montel voilà c'est parti pour la région
sorti en france l'américaine c'est le
pourtant pas rien jones mike c'est une
des plus grandes spécialistes du 400e
regarder comment marie jo est en train
d'avaler un américan john morris et va
ensuite partir à la poursuite de 110
riechers la jamaïcaine alors je vous
rappelle le chrono de larichaudy callas
50 secondes et 20 centièmes ce qui
correspond à la meilleure performance
mondiale de l'année
marie-josée l'a annoncé elle veut
descendre sous les 50 secondes pour
taper très très fort en gueule gorgue
font appel que marie josé pérec et
invaincu à la pointe sur 400 m mais
également sur 400 m haies et qu'elle a
quelques difficultés car elle ne
débouchera en tête des 80 le premier
titre à 107 et marie jo va devoir
récupérer messager du cros surprise
marie josé pérec et taboo et de cagnes
repasser pour sa première défaite de
l'année de marie josé pérec 50 secondes
et 35 centièmes vocable human et
peut-être peut-être un petit doute qui
est en train de s'installer à quelques
jours de göteborg journaleux tout avait
bousculé ce soir vous en doutez bien
nous allons venir au drame qui a
endeuillé le métro parisien cet après
midi avec probablement un attentat qui a
fait au moins quatre morts dans un
instant nous en parlerons avec un ancien
magistrat spécialiste de la lutte
antiterroriste alain marsaud auparavant
je vous propose de voir des images du
président jacques chirac qui s'est rendu
sur les lieux
je vous propose de découvrir ce
reportage il est 19 heures 45
l'évacuation des blessés comment
seulement au pont saint michel anna ils
sont allongés sur des civières et
transportés jusqu'aux ambulances du samu
du smur de la croix rouge et des
pompiers de paris
les plus gravement atteints sont
enveloppés dans des couvertures
d'amiante pour les réchauffer ils sont
parfois brûlés brièvement et tous un
étape chaud
au même moment sur la place notre-dame
trois hélicoptères atterrissent les uns
après les autres ils viennent pour les
blessés les plus touchés il est toujours
19h45
pendant que le ballet des ambulances
commence le président de la république
des sons dans le métro saint michel
[Musique]
je vous propose donc d'entendre le
commentaire d'alain marceau qui nous a
fait la gentillesse de venir sur ce
plateau dans ces circonstances
dramatiques
vous êtes maintenant député rpr mais
vous avez été longtemps magistrat
spécialiste de la lutte antiterroriste
alors bien évidemment il faut rester
extrêmement prudent
vous ne participez pas à l' enquête mais
vous connaissez très bien ce type de
dossier vous ai participé à l' enquête
sur d'autres attentats à paris
quelle est votre première réaction est
ce que selon vous c'est un attentat et
sur quelle piste pourrait-on se tourner
tout d'abord cela nous rappelle
étrangement ce que nous avons connu
hélas en 1986 où des attentats de cette
nature ont été commis sur le territoire
français souvenons nous tout cela et
cela entraînait plusieurs dizaines de
morts
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut
raisonner en terme soit de messages
soient de sanctions l'auteur de
l'attentât
l'auteur présumé d'attentât ou les
auteurs présumés de l'attentât ont voulu
soit sanctionné la france soit
effectivement faire passer un message
pourquoi il est préférable que notre
pays est considéré à tord ou à raison
comme ayant une politique étrangère
indépendante est en pointe dans certains
domaines c'est plutôt là en l'occurrence
une sanction qu'un message parce que là
on a vraiment voulu tuer de façon très
massives le métro à cette heure là je
crois qu'il faut se servir de clips de
l'expérience que nous avons accumulée au
cours des années notamment de 86 et 87
ou ans en grande que les attentats qui
ont été commis à cette époque était à la
fois une sanction mais aussi un message
ce message hélas nous avons mis près de
nantes malgré la détermination des
enquêteurs des magistrats et des
services de renseignements nous avons
mis près d'un an à le comprendre à
l'identifier et aboutir aux auteurs qui
nous avons eu beaucoup de chance crois
qu'aujourd'hui on peut être aussi bien
dans la phase sanction de messages alors
l'important c'est de comprendre très
rapidement messages de plus tôt possible
parce qu'il peut y avoir hélas un
deuxième message d'un troisième message
on évoquait tout falloir trois pistes
possibles la piste algérienne avec le
gia bon la situation en bosnie est ce
que les bosno serbes ont les moyens de
venir frapper comme ça à paris et puis
également la venue de l'effet rafa
demain et peut-être de l'association
franche orientale qui nous rattrape
après beaucoup d'autres et je crois
qu'on ne peut pas non plus ignorer
l'iran la libye et un certain nombre
d'états avec l'église l'air avec les
cales leur reprise essais nucléaires
avec lesquels nous pensons peut-être le
plus avoir de contentieux mais qui eux à
taureaux raison pense en avoir avec nous
en 1986 nous ne pensions pas à l'iran et
nous pensent avions pensé à l'époque
à la libye à la syrie et nous nous
sommes retrouvés sur la piste iranienne
effectivement il est apparu c'était les
iraniens donc aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faut être extrêmement prudentes
il a les pistes au calvaire de faire
allusion peut-être d'autres ce qui est
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui la france
est un pays ouvert
c'est bon c'est pas bon dans tous les
cas n'importe quel réseau peut s'y
installer dormir et est activée ou
réactivée à n'importe quel monde ça peut
être réseau algérien de type gia ça peut
être réseau libyen réseau iranien
pourquoi pas un réseau serbe mais
jusqu'ici les serbes nous avait pas
habitué à ce type d'exercice si vous
dites que c'est un avertissement un
message comment on va comprendre ce
message ce qu'il va y avoir des
revendications est ce que des gens vont
indirectement prendre contact avec avec
les autorités françaises pour faire
savoir exactement ce qu'ils veulent en
adressant ce message que j'ai c'est
terrible il est possible qu'ils aient
effectivement des relations des
revendications dans les jours qui
viennent
je pense qu'il faudra se méfier de la
première des revendications qu'alors
elle aura certainement pour objet de
nous perdre de plus donc je crois qu'il
faudra bien décrypter tout cela est la
première revendication rizet de la
mauvaise je vais dire alors soyons très
prudent là dessus je crois qu'ils vont
faire le véritable travail de police et
de renseignement
l'examen des explosifs l'examen des
personnes qui sont passées refaire les
relations de tous ceux que nous
connaissons je crois que notre histoire
hélas nous a permis aujourd'hui la clé
une culture de lutte antiterroriste qui
va sans doute être utilisé dans les
jours qui viennent devant c'est ma
question se demander puisque vous avez
hélas l'habitude de ce genre de travail
comment un magistrat instructeur
commence à travailler on étudie la
nature des explosifs ont laissé deux de
retrouver on analyse les fiches des gens
qui ont passé les douanes et les jours
précédents il ya bien sûr un travail de
police tout à fait classique avec examen
des explosifs l'examen des passagers
puis je crois que le gros du travail
il sera fait par les services de
renseignement lorsque les services de
renseignement auront pu acquérir
comment dirais-je un certain nombre de
pistes ou une piste que la justice
pourra effectivement intervenir si
toutefois il ya des identifications des
auteurs et là commencera la presse
judiciaire
je crois que ce qu'il faut souhaiter
c'est que cela se produise le plus
rapidement possible car hélas nous avons
mis un an je le dise en 1986 pour
aboutir
comment ça se passe pour les services
secrets ils vont commencer à travailler
elle d'abord avec la nature de
l'explosif ensuite ils vont faire
référence à ce qu'il sait pas ce qui
s'est passé auparavant
comment ensuite après ils ont essayé de
roewe retrouver le field de cet attentat
les services de renseignement ont vent
essayer d'identifier dans les dernières
manifestations qu'ils ont connu s'il y a
eu déjà un semblant de messages ici
effectivement une piste peut être
privilégié par rapport à l'autre par
exemple l'assassinât du shaq sahraoui il
ya quinze jours par le g20 à paris je ne
sais pas si on peut faire l'amalgamme de
tous ces faits qui à première vue semble
relativement différent je crois
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'il est en dehors
des auteurs personne ne sait exactement
qui imputer la responsabilité déjà
demain l'enquêteur un tout petit peu
avancé sur le plan judiciaire
et puis c'est à partir de des premiers
éléments d analyse que l'on pourra
véritablement déboucher sur une
véritable enquête éventuellement à une
autre identification des auteurs et
surtout identification des états il faut
bien se dire que même lorsqu on
identifie les états hélas il n'y a pas
de sanctions à l'égard des états il ya
parfois une sanction à l'égard des
auteurs mais pas les garder et train et
enrichissante au petit peu sur notre
faim
et souvenez-vous l'an dernier
l'arrestation de carlos à peu près la
même époque
c'est tout un grand moment de la lutte
antiterroriste aujourd'hui hélas
l'histoire nous réveille un peu
brutalement est ce que nos services
secrets vont travailler avec d'autres
services secrets sur une situation
permanente
oui c'est très semblable de l'autre côté
il faut savoir que les services secret
et bien c'est une des manifestations de
la souveraineté nationale donc que les
services secrets étrangers nous aiderons
dans la mesure où leurs intérêts le leur
permettent leurs conseils je crois qu'il
faut d'abord faire confiance en nous est
propre services secrets comme on l'a
fait en 1986 il faut se souvenir
d'ailleurs que à l'époque jacques chirac
qui était premier ministre à effet
particulièrement confiance dans les
magistrats que vous avez véritablement
confier la responsabilité de la lutte
antiterroriste et je crois qu'il avait
fait un bon choix puisque effectivement
cela a permis d'aboutir au bout d'un an
merci alain marsaud d'être venu sur le
plateau de jambes de france 2 je propose
de retrouver tout de suite en direct
propos de son père qui est sur les lieux
du drame
formation que nous avons donc les
opérations de secours ici sont terminées
place saint michel
je vous rappelle le bilan donné tout à
l'heure pour le directeur des opérations
de secours
quatre morts 14 blessés dans un état
extrêmement grave et 47 blessés ce qu'on
sait pour le moment donc il s'agit d'une
explosion extrêmement fortes dans une
dans la voiture numéro six du rer b
c'est un air qui venait de la gare du
nord et qui se dirigeait vers saint rémy
les chevreuse le rer
arrivé dans cette station saint-michel
ition plein centre de paris au moment où
il arrive à quai une très forte
explosion au milieu de la voiture numéro
6 est donc quatre morts 14 blessés
graves 47 blessés actuellement tous les
blessés ont été évacués et se trouve
dans la plupart des hôpitaux de la
région parisienne
la plupart des personnalités qui sont
venus ici tout de suite dans une dans un
climat vous pouvez l'imaginer empreint
d'une très très forte émotion le
président jacques chirac qui n'a fait
aucun commentaire
il est descendu dans le métro pour se
rendre compte un petit peu la situation
le maire de paris est le premier
ministre monsieur juppé actuellement je
sais pas si vous pouvez le voir si la
caméra nous quitte un instant sur ses
plages saint michel
on peut le voir il ya encore mon
quelques ambulances mais la plupart des
victimes toutes les victimes ont en fait
été évacuée et actuellement sur ces
places se trouvent essentiellement des
véhicules de police les enquêteurs
assistés des magistrats antiterroristes
se trouve actuellement sous mes pieds je
veux dire il se trouve dans cette
station de rer
et effectivement ils commencent leur
long travail d'investigation
il leur faudra maintenant déterminer
s'il s'agit bien d'un attentat et il
faudra très vite et terminer en tous les
cas la nature de l'explosif tous les
témoins que nous avons pu rencontrer
parle d'une explosion extrêmement
violente
vers 17 heures voilà ce qu'on peut dire
pour le moment ici en direct depuis ces
places amis seul où je vous rappelle les
opérations de secours sont maintenant
terminées place maintenant l'anc est une
enquête évidemment qui s'annonce
extrêmement difficile
merci claude son père je rappelle le
numéro de téléphone que vous pouvez
joindre pour connaître l'identité des
victimes car bien sûr il y avait
énormément de monde dans le rer vers
5h05 heure et demie cet après midi il
s'agit du 36e 68 77 14
nous allons terminer ce journal avec jf
vite ambert qui est en direct de l'hôtel
dieu
mais ici c'est un petit peu comme la
place sur la place saint michel nous
sommes en fait à 200 m
de cet endroit ici à l'hôtel dieu où la
place a retrouvé un certain calme
maintenant les rotations d'hélicoptères
ont un peu ralenti leur rythme vous le
voyez derrière nous sur le parvis de
l'église notre dame les hélicoptères
sont maintenant placés au sol je pense
que la majorité des blessés comme le
disait claude son père ont été orientés
vers les hôpitaux de paris et de la
région parisienne je vous rappelle
qu'ici à l'hôtel dieu on accueille
principalement à les blessés légers
il n'empêche que tout le monde est sur
le pont sellal et retroussé le plan
rouge et tous les infirmiers tous les
médecins
toutes les personnes de l'hôpital sont
mobilisés pour ce soir et bien sûr pour
la nuit le cij habitants berre alors
encore une fois il s'agit de rester
extrêmement prudent encore une fois la
thèse de l'attentât n'est pas
officiellement annoncé mais il y a de
très très fortes présomptions pour
reprendre les termes d'alain juppé jean
michel carpentier est encore une fois en
restant extrêmement prudent est ce qu'on
peut faire un premier commentaire sur
d'hypothétiques thèse d'atlanta oui
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure prudence plusieurs pistes sont
envisageables soit la situation
algérienne et un attentat du gia quinze
jours après l'assassinât à paris du
chèque sahraouis qui était un des
fondateurs du fils ou alors la situation
au proche orient avec la venue de yasser
arafat de même un prix juste après
l'attentât du mouvement hamas terrible
attentat hier à tel aviv en israël ou
alors la situation en bosnie au moment
où la france fait preuve de fermeté pour
contenir les avancées des bosno serbes
on peut également évoquer la reprise
essai nucléaire l'enquète sera difficile
elle a commencé n'y a toujours pas de
revendication officielle il faut donc
attendre les travaux de la police et des
services secrets
et puis souhaiter que les choses vont
rester là merci jean michel carpentier
gens
philippe lefait reviendra bien
évidemment très très longuement sur ce
drame
dans le dernier journal vers 1h du matin
tout de suite la météo d'isabel martinez
avec une journée plutôt maussade de
demain excellente soirée à demain
[Musique]
gérard klein marlène jobert les
cavaliers de l'orage ou le coup de
foudre a tout de suite du coup de
tonnerre des précipitations et surtout
beaucoup de températures elles resteront
encore chaudes demain matin avec des
valeurs comprises entre 16 et 20 degrés
au nord de la loire le maximum pour
nantes et un maximum de 23 degrés à
perpignan et dans la région dans l'après
midi les températures seront en baisse
sous les orages qui est à peu près
logique ça nous donnera tout juste 22
degrés à brest en revanche encore 30 à
strasbourg il faudra jusqu'à 32 degrés
autour de la méditerranée
il est en vacances voici la météo des
plages nous partons tout d'abord au bord
des côtes de la manche avec dans
l'ensemble un temps orageux mais la mer
restera bel de calais à saint brieuc
18-19 dans l'eau et à l'index uv modéré
sur les côtes atlantiques le drapeau sur
un verre mais les nuages défileront 26 à
26 sur la plage 17 à 23 dans l'eau et un
index uv là encore modérée enfin autour
de la méditerranée des nuages sur le
roussillon et plein soleil ailleurs des
températures chaudes et sur le sac 33
degrés et dans l'eau jusqu'à 27 degrés
un index uv encore élevé qui ne
permettra pas d'exposer les tout petits
avec une crème indice 40 qui sera
fortement conseillée si vous devez
voyager hors de france
eh bien vous aurez du soleil notamment
sur l'afrique du nord avec 36degres à
tunis
vous subirez des orages entre berne et
sofia ailleurs un temps variable
notamment sur le nord du continent avec
23 de grâce au col et de la pluie à
dublin avec 20 degrés et maintenant je
vous emmène au croisic visiter
l'océarium qui vient d'accueillir une
nouvelle génération de pensionnaires il
s'agit de manchots qu'il ne faut surtout
pas confondre avec leurs cousins les
pingouins précision les manchots ne vole
pas évident dans l'hémisphère sud
ceux là sont toutefois nées en
angleterre dans le cadre d'un programme
européen de reproduction que d'oiseaux
marins passent les trois quarts de leur
temps dans l'eau grâce à leur forme
hydrodynamique ils peuvent atteindre une
vitesse de 30 km à l'heure de
tempérament joueur
le manchot apprécie particulièrement les
moments qu'il passe avec son soigneur le
repas trois fois par jour constitue donc
une véritable animation qui ravit les
petits
tout autant que les grands voilà demain
nous serons le mercredi 26 juillet le
jour de la sainte anne vous retrouverez
laurent romejko dès demain matin
il me reste à vous souhaiter une
excellente soirée merci au revoir
[Musique]
rebond soir avec l'ensemble de nos
envies spéciaux nous allons bien
évidemment revenir sur l'événement
dramatique et endeuillé la capitale cet
après midi l' explosion probablement un
attentat dans la station rer
saint-michel au coeur de paris qui a
fait quatre morts et 62 blessés dont 16
dans un état extrêmement grave
maryse burgot il est un peu plus de
17h40 quand les premiers blessés sont
évacués
devant la station saint-michel premières
images de gens visiblement très choquée
parce qu'ils viennent de vivre dès les
premières minutes de l'attentât un poste
médical avancé est installé dans le var
situé juste à côté de la station
saint-michel
selon nos informations il y aurait donc
quatre morts et plusieurs dizaines de
blessés parmi les passagers du rer mais
également parmi les piétons qui
circulent et à ce moment là aux abords
de la station saint michel toutes les
ambulances de paris et de sa banlieue
ont été mobilisés certains blessés ont
été soignés sur la voie publique selon
les pompiers
la déflagration aurait été très
importante et l'explosion aurait eu lieu
au milieu de la ram
nous avions commencé l'évacuation des
victimes il nous restait trois victimes
incarcérées
nous sommes en train de les dégager dans
le wagon sinon l'ensemble des autres
victimes sont prises en charge par les
équipes médicales du samu et de la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
sur les lieux combien de personnes
combien de personnes soient aussi
déployés il ya au moins 200 personnes
entre deux et trois cents personnes sur
les lieux
sapeurs-pompiers plus à me faut compter
entre 3 400 personnes
les premières minutes de l'attentât les
victimes ont été tenus à l'écart des
journalistes
pendant ce temps dans le métro interdit
à la presse des chirurgiens se sont vus
obligés de procéder à des amputations à
l'extérieur ce qui était loin de
l'explosion et qui ne sont pas blessés
racontent ce qu'ils ont vu ce qu'ils ont
entendus
on était dans le rer et
une grosse déflagration est très forte
et du souffle je pense que ça s'est
passé dans la voiture derrière moi il
n'y a pas eu trop de panique les gens
sont sortis comme ça il ya eu beaucoup
de fumée me suis revenu sur mes pas pour
voir ce qui s'était passé il avait
besoin d'une fumée non je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de victimes de gens quitter
assez grièvement blessé et puis tu vois
là jusqu aux gens sans aider à s'aider
les uns les autres et tout ça fait un
peu faux quoi c'est comme si c'était pas
pour de vrai mais fait je suis sur ma
lancée pour de vrai quoi on sait pas
exactement d'où elle est venue
l'explosion on était dans les voitures
donc que ces ses clés la déflagration
s'est produite vers l'intérieur de la
voiture puisque toutes les vitres ont
posé à l'intérieur de la voiture
et puis on va presser la scène d'horreur
[Musique]
des blessés partout monsieur qu'est ce
que vous avez vu enfants moi j'étais sur
le quai en wagon de tête et j'ai vu une
boule de feu à peu près 2 mètres 50 au
dessus du au dessus du sol sur l'arrière
du maine de la ram
enfin ça m'a paru sur l'arrière de la
rame au dessus du quai donc eu beaucoup
de ce mouvement de personnes tout de
suite ce qui m'est arrivé lentement puis
après s'épaissit énormément le blessé
ont été orientés vers les hôpitaux de
paris et de sa banlieue
équipés de services de pathologie grave
certains ont dû être évacués par
hélicoptère
[Musique]
quatre heures après ce drame je vous
propose de faire le point de la
situation sur place avec l'autre son
père et un dernier point donc ici les
opérations de secours sont terminées sur
cette place saint michel à mes côtés le
lieutenant-colonel marescq des sapeurs
pompiers le colonel est ce que vous
pouvez tout d'abord rappelé le bilan
le bilan est il est assez lourd quatre
personnes décédées
quatorze blessés graves ou très graves
et 47 personnes plus légèrement blessés
ce dernier chiffre pouvant encore
évoluer parce que certaines personnes
ont pu fuir spontanément et lorsqu'ils
auront retrouvé leur calme
elle le risque de revenir se présenter
actuellement vous le confirmer les
opérations de secours sont terminées les
opérations de secours sur les victimes
graves sont terminées ces victimes sont
évacués par les ambiances réanimation
des pompiers et du samu sur les hôpitaux
parisiens et par hélicoptère un plan
rouge déclenché donc mobilisation
générale des secours samu pompiers où je
descendu en bas que ça ressemble bien
c'est une explosion qui s'est produit la
6ème voiture tête de la 6e voiture elle
a touché principalement ce compartiment
et je pense qu'il y avait de nombreuses
personnes à ce niveau là
ceux qui vont les a touchés très gramat
mais peut-être paradoxalement a pu
protéger les autres voilà donc les
opérations de secours sont terminées sur
la place saint michel place actuellement
lankais de très nombreux enquêteurs se
trouvent actuellement sous nos pieds
donc dans cette station deux erreurs
essaye actuellement au milieu des débris
au milieu des décombres de déterminer la
nature de l'explosion et s'il en est
fautif la nature de cet explosif pour le
moment vous l'avez dit pas de
confirmation officielle de l'attentât
mais évidemment tout le monde ici pense
à un attentat merci claude son père on
l'a dit tous les blessés ont été
hospitalisés et l'assistance publique il
faut pour vous retrouver j'évite tomber
requête en direct de l'hôtel dieu oui
l'hôtel-dieu la place de l'hôtel dieu
qui vient tout juste d'être rendus
libres à la circulation des piétons et
des voitures on voit ici passer beaucoup
de monde l'air un peu abasourdi des gens
qui viennent probablement de la place
saint-michel qui se trouve à à peine 200
mètres d'ici sur le plan médical comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure
l'hôtel-dieu n'accueille pas les
personnes qui sont les plus gravement
atteintes car elle ne dispose pas des
structures idoines
en revanche ces personnes les cas les
plus graves sont orientés vers d'autres
hôpitaux de paris et de la région
parisienne la pitié salpêtrière
notamment également
vital cochin qui dispose lui d'un
service d'appels pour les grands des
grands brûlés par dont on sait que
beaucoup de personnes souffrent ce soir
de ce type de blessure ce qu'on peut
dire également ses convois rappliquer en
quelque sorte le personnel hospitalier
dans tout son ensemble nous voyons
passer des médecins des infirmiers qui
viennent renforcer les effectifs qui
viennent donner à la fois des moyens et
du courage car on va passer de
nombreuses heures cette nuit à tenter de
guérir les personnes qui ont été
blessées dans cet attentat
merci j'évite tombèrent jacques chirac
s'est rendu immédiatement sur les lieux
de ce drame la station saint-michel à
paris
je pose de voir le reportage de florence
bukiya l'évacuation des blessés comment
seulement au pont saint michel
anna ils sont allongés sur des civières
et transportés jusqu'aux ambulances du
samu du smur de la croix rouge et des
pompiers de paris
les plus gravement atteints sont
enveloppés dans des couvertures
d'amiante pour les réchauffer ils sont
parfois brûlé grièvement et tous un
étape chaud ou même moment sur la place
notre-dame
trois hélicoptères atterrissent les uns
après les autres ils viennent pour les
blessés les plus touchés il est toujours
19h45
pendant que le ballet des ambulances
commence le président de la république
défend dans le métro saint michel
jean michel carpentier jacques chirac
avait connu des circonstances aussi
dramatiques analogue à la suite de sa
nomination comme premier ministre en 86
le jour même de cette nomination
il y avait eu un attentat à la galerie
point chaud à paris sur les champs
elysées oui mais la situation n'est
probablement pas la même à l'élysée
chaîne contacter l'elysée on reste
extrêmement prudent le président la
république a immédiatement réagi en
faisant dans sur place il ne fera pas de
déclaration ce soir trois mots et
explique son attitude le recueillement
la dignité et la détermination bien sûr
il n'y a pas encore de conclusions
officielles concernant un attentat même
si tout semble l'indiquer
alors prudence le 14 juillet dernier je
vous rappelle jacques chirac avait
affirmé que la france ne devait pas
devenir une base arrière du terrorisme
d'où immédiatement une série de
décisions d'urgence prises autour de la
de parler à cri la cellule de crise qui
a été mise en place au ministère de
l'intérieur
le musée intérieur jean louis debré a
annoncé qu'il y aurait un renforcement
de la surveillance des bâtiments vides
et des lieux publics
un renforcement de la surveillance des
transports en commun et de tous les
lieux de forte affluence un rang
forcément des contrôles dans les
aéroports et à nos frontières l' enquête
est désormais dans les mains de la
police et des services secrets qui va
qui vont analyser les explosifs
s'il s'agit bien explosif qui vont
comparer avec d'autres attentats du
passé c'est à dire un très très long
travail
merci jean michel carpentier encore une
fois il faut rester extrêmement prudent
la thèse même de l'attentât n'est pas
encore officiellement présenté cela dit
philippe harrouard on peut dès ce soir
tenter d'ébaucher quelques pistes
quelques hypothèses oui bien sûr vous
avez raison peut être extrêmement
prudent on pense d'abord à la piste
algérienne pourquoi et bien parce que le
12 juillet dernier s'est passé également
sur notre sol à paris un événement
extraordinaire qui est l'attentât contre
l'imam de la rue myrha dans le 18e
arrondissement le cheikh sahraoui est
l'un des créateurs du fils et on avait
dit à l'époque qu'il n'y a pas très
longtemps donc on a dit attention c'est
peut-être une exportation du climat de
terreur qui règne en ce moment en
algérie sur notre sol donc c'est la
première piste à laquelle on pense
il ya une autre piste c'est celle du
moyen-orient le président de l'autorité
palestinienne yasser arafat se rend
demain à paris pour voir sa petite fille
puisqu'il est papa est ce tellement se
produit alors que hier il y a eu un très
grave attentat à tel-aviv revendiquée
par le hamas un très grave attentat qu
yasser arafat a fermement condamné car
les négociations de paix sur le proche
orient vont quand même se poursuivre
alors ça ce sont deux pistes qui sont
élire et qui vient évidemment à l'esprit
il peut y en avoir d'autres l'iran
l'iran qui était responsable d'un
certain nombre d'attentats il ya
plusieurs années la libye et puis bon
voilà je crois que nous avions tout à
l'heure comme invité le juge marceau
nous disait lui-même que dès demain
les enquêteurs vont commencer mais qu'
il ce n'est pas forcé que tout de suite
il ya une revendication et surtout que
tout de suite on connaît à peu près
l'origine de ce terrible attentat donc
qui a fait quatre morts dans un instant
nous allons tendre le commentaire
d'alain juppé qui s'est rendu lui aussi
bien sûr immédiatement sur les lieux du
drame
une dernière information jean michel
cornil acision assez importante
en fait sur la façon dont ces procédés
cet attentat à la bombe a explosé aurait
explosé selon des sources autorisées à
l'intérieur de la rame au moment où le
train s'immobilise et
en station les portes étant encore
fermée cette bombe se trouvait placé
sous un siège de victimes ont été
principalement atteinte aux jambes et au
bassin
la majorité des personnes blessées l'ont
été à l'intérieur de la rame voilà il
s'agit donc apparemment bien d'une bombe
merci je vous disais alain juppé s'est
rendu immédiatement sur les lieux ce
drame je vous propose de voir ce
reportage et d'entendre les déclarations
du premier ministre
donc en bière réaction est évidemment
être bouleversée devant julien de loi en
l'état actuel des choses
quatre victimes qui sont décédées et
quarantaine une cinquantaine de blessés
dans un état plus ou moins graves
l'explosion de très forte puissance
vienne permet encore d'affirmer qu'il
s'agit d'un attentat mais les
présomptions ensemble
très fort il va bien sûr incliné à la
mémoire des listings
des foyers coup d'essai du gouvernement
est pressé qui sont traités sur place
quand vous savez que nous avec lui en
règle et dans les champs médical sera
également rendre hommage la vitesse la
qualité dans des camps de la police et
pompiers qui ont été surpris c'est tout
divisé et quand j'allais vendre le plan
pour le reste en quête libre
et qu'ils auront
les plus d'informations je pense dans
les heures qui suivent
une déclaration enregistrée vers 19
heures je vous propose de retrouver
claude son père vous venez d'entendre
monsieur juppé le premier ministre donc
beaucoup d'émotion il ya quelques
minutes est arrivé également le ministre
de l'intérieur jean louis debré qui ont
envoyé ces images
jean louis debré effectivement qui n'a
fait aucune déclaration il est encore
actuellement sur place il s'est rendu
lui aussi sur les lieux de cette de
cette explosion il faut encore rester
prudent puisque la thèse de l'attentât
n'est pas confirmée donc pour le moment
qu'une déclaration de jean lui devrait
beaucoup de prudence et je voulais dit
les opérations de secours ici sont
terminées place maintenant à lenquête
une enquête qui s'annonce très difficile
première tâche des enquêteurs déterminer
s'il y avait des explosifs dans cette
voiture 6 si oui quelle était la nature
de ces explosifs
je vous rappelle que pour le moment il
n'y a aucune revendication
merci nous aurions bien évidemment sur
ce drame cette explosion dans le métro
parisien qui a fait quatre morts et une
quinzaine de blessés très grièvement
atteints dans lors d'une édition
spéciale préparé par la rédaction de
france 2 juste après la diffusion du
film cavaliers de l'orage a tout de
suite
[Musique]